people often ask whether its nature or
nurture that creates a serial killer
well it's actually both and more I like
to say that genetics loads the gun
personality and psychology image and
your experiences pull the trigger your
genetics give you the potentiality to be
killer but your personality and
psychology are the filter through which
you experience and they can change how
you come away from any event in your
life
I'm Jim Clemente I'm a retired FBI
Supervisory Special Agent and profiler
in the Behavioral Analysis Unit as a
profiler my job was to hunt down child
abductors
serial rapists and serial killers we
help out where forensics fail if we look
at how the crime was committed that
leads us to why the crime was committed
and that leads us to who committed the
crime the FBI's Behavioral Analysis Unit
is part of the National Center for the
analysis of violent crime and as such we
study all violent and sexual crimes
across this country and much of it
around the world so that we can then
train law enforcement so that they can
get the benefit of our research in our
training the original FBI profilers dick
all John Douglas Roy Hazelwood Robert
Ressler Pete's Merrick they gain this
body of knowledge by actually going into
prisons and interviewing convicted
serial killers they interview them in
great detail about what they did and
also how they grew up and how they felt
during the entire time that they were
killing people developing this criminal
expertise and that they were getting
away with these crimes
for example form ed Kemper they learned
that he had a very difficult
relationship with his mother so he
started killing surrogates in place of
her and then he killed his mother David
Berkowitz showed how sexual frustration
can be taken out on innocent people on
the streets of New York
from Ted Bundy they learned that he was
a sexual sadist that he got off on
causing and witnessing the pain and
suffering of others but he did that many
times by using his psychopathic charm to
lure in victims and he feigned injury so
that it was the people who wanted to
help him that he ended up killing so now
we have an amazing volume of
institutional knowledge about these
offenders and it tells us how they
killed and why they killed and it helps
us to hunt them down criminal profiling
is basically reverse engineering a crime
we look at the victimology the choice of
the victims we look at the crime scene
we look at the organization level and
then pre and post offense behavior and
together all those things tell us the
kind of person who committed the crime
victimology is the study of the victim
their life their desires their education
their daily routine because an offender
picks a particular victim at a
particular place at a particular time in
a particular manner for a particular
purpose and all those choices leak out
information about the offender about
their skills and abilities about their
desires and they can lead us right back
to the offender the crime location can
tell us a lot did the crime occur on a
farm in the middle of Iowa where the
only potential witnesses are a bunch of
cows and pigs or did it happen in New
York City's Times Square where at any
given moment there may be fifty to a
hundred thousand potential eyewitnesses
pulling off a crime in either of those
locations tells you a lot about the
offender at the crime scene we look at
the offender's behavior how much time
did they spend there what was their
interaction with the victims and what
was their criminal sophistication level
the choice of weapons that an offender
uses at a crime scene reveals a
tremendous amount of information about
them did the offender use a gun and kill
somebody from a distance or did they get
up close and personal and use a knife
that's
different kind of person who typically
is engaged in different kinds of
profession than somebody who will not
get up close and personal next we look
at the offenders organization level the
two types of offenders that we see are
on a spectrum between organized and
disorganized the organized offender will
plan it in advance fantasize about
committing the crime and then bring all
the implements necessary to commit the
crime and then take them away with him
after the crime whereas the disorganized
offender is impulsive it don't plan the
crimes out in advance they may have
lowered inhibitions because of drug or
alcohol use and they basically pick up
the implements along the way and may
leave them behind leaving a lot of
forensic evidence for law enforcement to
find if an offender doesn't have a very
high skill level in terms of getting
access to victims they'll pick victims
who lead very high-risk lives
prostitutes and drug addicts whereas a
very sophisticated offender will be able
to acquire victims in the privacy and
security of their own homes it takes a
much different level of criminal
sophistication to be able to accomplish
those two different crimes the next
level of criminal behavioral analysis is
looking at pre and post offense behavior
if they're organized offenders they
probably did pre offense surveillance to
check out the location maybe even
surveil potential victims and stalk them
also we find that offenders after they
commit a serious criminal offense will
have behavioral changes that people
around them might see for example if an
offender has committed an abduction and
murder they would likely leave the area
making up an excuse in emergency to get
out of town and they wouldn't return
until everything calmed down and they
felt it was safe to come back building a
profile is simply taking all of those
five factors and looking at what
information the offender leaks out by
behaving in those particular waves
[Music]
when I analyze a crime scene I look at
various types of evidence some of which
we have here pictures inside the house
where the crime occurred crime-scene
photographs autopsy pictures as well as
an affidavit summarizing the facts of
the case and the crime scene description
typically I'd like to ask a lot more
questions and get much more data but I
think we have enough at least now to
start a preliminary profile so I'm
looking at a case of a double homicide
of a male and female the male appears to
be in his early 20s he was shot about
five times he has an unknown
relationship to the female victim who
appears to have been pregnant and she
was shot seven to eight times in her
face and head and upper torso it also
appears that the male may have scrawled
in grease several letters he's found on
the floor of the back room by the back
door she's found in a room next to it
half hanging off the bed with her head
on a couch that's pushed up right next
to the bed it appears that she was first
shot while she was laying on her back on
the bed
and that she either rolled over to try
to get away or was flipped over by
someone and shot again where she died in
place my first impressions are that the
male victim was killed first that he was
a practical kill to get him out of the
way whereas the female victim was shot
multiple times in the chest and at least
once in the face and another time in the
head she appears to be the main target
of this attack so if we start with
victimology we know that the first
victim the male grew up in this town and
had left town for
several years and came back he's got no
known criminal history yet in this house
$11,000 in cash was found three and a
half pounds marijuana was found and
powdery substance that appeared to be
drugs was also found that tells me that
they were engaged in a high-risk
activity drug trafficking but the fact
that the drugs and the money were left
behind tells me there's a high
probability that this was not a
drug-related hit I believe that if drug
dealers were involved in this they would
have taken the drugs and they would have
taken the cash this tells me there's a
level of immaturity in this offender
somebody who didn't have the presence of
mind to search for these things or
didn't even think that they might be
there I would put the intelligence level
of the offender at mid to low because
they made a flimsy attempt at cleaning
up after themselves and that could also
mean that their inhibitions were
diminished by drugs or alcohol something
that's particularly unusual in this
crime scene is the letters that are
scrawled on the floor apparently by the
male victim with grease that was
squirted onto the floor they attempt it
appears to spell out a name jmf and then
under that the ope sort of a last dying
declaration this could indicate either a
person or some kind of motive as a
criminal behavioral analyst I want to
determine whether this is an actual
message that was left by the dying male
or whether this is staging in order to
misdirect investigators so I'd like to
know if he had grease on one or more of
his hands or fingers and whether or not
he was left-handed or right-handed and
whether or not that was the hand that
had the grease on it the organization
leveled this crime is fairly low even
though the offender brought the gun he
used to commit the murders with him he
left forensic evidence behind and that
tells me he doesn't have a
high level of forensic or criminal
sophistication we look at pre and post
defense behavior since it doesn't look
like he's very criminally sophisticated
this could be one of the only times he
committed a crime like this and I
believe that he may have gone into a
panic afterwards I would think that
somewhere between where he committed
these crimes and where he went you would
find the weapon in a dumpster a body of
water or a place he thought it would be
hidden I would also expect somebody like
that to make an excuse to either leave
the area or leave town for a period of
time until everything calms down so in
this case I believe that how the victims
were killed tells us a story I believe
he was a practical kill and she was the
target of this double homicide also the
fact that she was pregnant may indicate
that the why was jealousy and that there
was another person sort of a love
triangle here and that the person
responsible was the third person in this
love triangle or a family member
in the DC sniper case the entire
Washington DC area was terrorized for 23
days a number of random people were shot
and killed or injured it turns out this
was a longer spree that had started in
the state of Washington and spanned the
entire country so I became involved in
the case because I was working the
Behavioral Analysis Unit at the time and
we consulted on the investigation
immediately this case presented as if it
were a spree killing six murders in the
space of 27 hours so we didn't think he
was targeting a particular type of group
the victimology was completely random
typically in Spri cases the offender is
on the run and commits murder after
murder after murder but he compensates
over that time the rush of adrenaline
and the excitement and the fear of
getting away all those things can cause
an offender to make more mistakes as
time goes on but in this case that
wasn't happening the shootings
themselves indicated that there was pre
attack surveillance this offender
planned and executed six murders within
the space of 27 hours it was a ghost no
one even saw him that told us right away
that he had a certain level of calm cool
and collected news that he was probably
in his mid to late 40s and had police or
military training but more than that he
must have actually had experience on the
streets as a police officer or on the
battlefield because pulling the trigger
on a paper target is one thing but
taking the life of an unknown individual
is a whole nother matter so when we
started the profile we based it only on
statistics and statistically snipers are
in their 40s or 50s white males and they
have a grudge against society or
somebody in particular that they take
out on their victims
another thing about snipers is that they
have a god complex they want to take
life from afar and above so they can
feel omnipotent like God and because of
that it's very important to appease them
not challenge them unfortunately that's
not what law enforcement was doing at
the time they called them in coward
and they said the streets are safe and
the schools are safe so the sniper shot
a kid walking into school the next day
but they left a tarot card the death
card and on that car there was
indications of duality first of all it
said call me God which reinforced our
opinion that the sniper had a god
complex
and it went on to say this is for you
mister police and that looks as though
the writer is looking up to the police
calling them mister police it also has
its origins in a number of reggae songs
so that could mean that the offender had
a Caribbean influence but then it said
do not release to the press and press is
an older word something that older
people use which is consistent with the
level of sophistication of planning and
executing these crimes but not
consistent with looking up to the police
so for the first time we had to consider
whether this offender was calm cool and
collected when he plans and executes his
murders but he decompensates when he's
writing or for the first time in US
history we have a sniper team one older
in his mid 40s and one younger in his
teens but the fact is that we know that
because snipers have a god complex they
don't work well together so i theorize
that the older one was actually
controlling the younger one and I went
as far as saying that he may be
controlling him through sexual
victimization because that would give
him complete control over the younger
person in fact 10 years after they were
caught and convicted Malvo disclosed
that Mohammad had been sexually
victimizing it the whole time so in the
end our profile was that of two snipers
working together both African American
one in his mid 40s
having police or military training and
experienced one in his teens
once we released that profile and
because of other work that the FBI was
doing
that reinforced our profile Muhammad and
Malvo were arrested within 24 hours
developing the profile in the DC sniper
case was groundbreaking because in the
vast majority of previous sniper cases
in the United States of America they
were committed by lone offenders who
were white male who were in their 40s or
50s with a particular grudge and this
case blew that profile to pieces as
criminal behavioral analysts we look at
how the offender committed the crime and
determine why they committed the crime
and that leads us to who committed the
crime in many of these cases local law
enforcement has absolutely no idea who
committed the crime and no leads but
criminal behavioral analysis can
generate leads as to the type of person
who committed the crime and in many
cases across the country criminal
behavioral analysis has led to the
identification arrest and conviction of
the offenders
[Music]